bienvenue à la facture la part de toute
l'équipe bonne année vous avez peut-être
fêté en prenant un petit verre ou un
petit joint parce que le cannabis c'est
légal mais ça ne l'est pas pour les
jeunes sauf que bien des jeunes se
tournent vers le marché noir et vers un
nouveau produit qu'on appelle la wax et
vous allez voir que la wax c'est pas mal
plus dangereux comme ci-joint
[Musique]
je me suis dit bon c'est du pas
que ça
imaginez un cannabis 15 fois plus fort
qu'il y a 50 ans dans le goût et la
forte odeur sont remplacés par une
saveur de bonbons le produit est
attrayant prête à consommer voici la
vapoteuse de Wax les jeunes en raffolent
à s'en détruire le cerveau
[Musique]
mon garçon c'est un enfant qui performe
très bien à l'école on vient rentrer à
la polyvalence super bien de très bonnes
notes je vous dirais jusqu'au secondaire
4 il y arrivait de plus en plus défoncé
à la maison cette mère que l'on
appellera Brigitte ne reconnaît plus son
fils de 15 ans depuis qu'il consomme de
la boîte lorsqu'il en manque il devient
violent
la première crise qui est arrivée c'est
vraiment la bousculade avec ma part
c'est disjoncté complètement et j'avais
aucun contrôle dessus j'ai dû contacter
la police trois fois depuis les six
derniers mois pour la porte à l'hôpital
c'est un concentré d'huile de cannabis
sur Internet cette drogue illégale
partout au pays est vendu dans une
vapoteuse elle ressemble à s'y méprendre
à une vapoteuse de nicotine la wax a une
forte teneur en THC la docteur Marie-Ève
Morin connaît bien les troubles de santé
mentale et de dépendance le THC on sait
que c'est l'ingrédient psychotrope qui
gèle dans le cannabis dans les années 60
70 ça dépend de Woodstock donc quand les
gens fumaient du cannabis quand on avait
un cannabis à 5% de THC Stains mais avec
la wax on va chercher des taux de THC
au-dessus de 90%
avec petit liquide dedans que aucune
odeur pour ma part moi j'avais jamais vu
ça je lui ai laissé je lui ai carrément
laissé
Saverne que ça au fil du temps Brigitte
découvre que son fils consomme de la wax
tous les jours c'est une consommation
moins constante du matin jusqu'au soir
et même on a eu des épisodes où ce qui
se levaient la nuit pour consommer donc
c'est
mon fils c'est un vide qui sent
l'intérieur qui m'exprime quelqu'un qui
consomme mais il s'en passe
de tourner
[Musique]
ce jeune consommateur que nous
appellerons Maxime qui n'est pas le fils
de Brigitte a commencé la consommation
de Wax à 14 ans dans la cour de son
école secondaire
[Musique]
c'est quelque chose tu veux te poser
plus que d'habitude je le vois comme une
nouvelle expérience puis finalement je
suis tombé assez rapidement là dedans je
pourrais dire que ça me mettait un peu
dans les vent
je voyais un peu la vie en rose on peut
dire ça j'aimais cookies
à savoir de Smarties M&M bubble gum et
ça goûte les fruits et ça coûte 40
dollars pour une centaine de doses donc
c'est du pote
prêt à porter
pour seulement 40 sous la dose les
jeunes obtiennent un puissant effet de
THC
pour voir comment il est facile de s'en
procurer nous assistons à l'achat de 12
vapoteuses par des consommateurs
pourtant illégal au Québec ils les ont
reçu par la poste sans aucun problème
même que certaines entreprises offrent
la livraison en personne à la porte
intercepter tous les colis dans lesquels
il y aurait un wax et pratiquement
impossible Jean-Sébastien falu et
professeur à l'Université de Montréal et
fondateur de grippe un organisme
communautaire qui aide les jeunes
toxicomanes c'est pas le seul produit
qu'on a de la misère à contrôler sur
l'internet c'est pour ça que c'est
vraiment comme un peu un vœux pieux de
pensée
empêcher l'accès c'est pas possible les
adolescents n'ont qu'à cocher qu'ils
sont majeurs ils en achètent en grande
quantité et les revendre dans la rue à
l'unité
j'ai commencé à en vendre fin de pas
trop à peu près je me faisais texter
toute la journée par des gens qui ont
voulu
les 12 vapoteuses achetées sur internet
par les consommateurs proviennent de
trois entreprises canadiennes il s'agit
de mourac mais de base situé à
shannonville en Ontario
07 en ligne basée également en Ontario
et restez gauche cannabis qui est situé
au Québec et leur boutique est très
visible même si la loi québécoise
interdit toute vente ailleurs qu'à la
sqdc ce que je constate par rapport à la
West qui me fascine c'est la facilité
d'accès et l'autre chose qui me fascine
c'est c'est la très pour ça caché dans
la Manche
ça
commence en 6e maintenant c'est
incroyable sixième année les gens ont
des droits
les fabricants visent directement les
jeunes tant par la saveur que par
l’emballage pourtant les lois sont
claires au Canada il est interdit de
vendre du cannabis dans un emballage qui
pourrait être attrayant pour les jeunes
et qui a un goût autre que celui du
cannabis misé sur les savants les
couleurs l'emballage c'est une tactique
de l'industrie de toutes sortes de
tactiques comme ça qui sont très bien
documentés scientifiquement comme étant
efficaces pour aller chercher les jeunes
et c'est très déploré en santé publique
c'est encore une période la vie où le
cerveau peut être très vulnérable aux
effets du cannabis puis causer des
dépendances le docteur Chady et pédiatre
et œuvre en prévention et au traitement
de la toxicomanie chez les adolescents
moi ça m'est arrivé de voir des jeunes
qui démontrent des symptômes un peu
pré-psychotiques c'est-à-dire des signes
avant-coureurs d'une psychose qui
pourrait être en train de s'installer
lesquels ça pourrait être de l'anxiété
très sévère la sensation de se faire
suivre par quelqu'un d'être toujours
surveillé un peu une déconnexion avec la
réalité parfois d'entendre des sons des
voix de voir des choses qui sont pas
toujours là je prendrai mon jeune et je
l'enverrai en cure de désintox
malheureusement c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe aussi il faut que les jeunes
cautionne la cure de désintox pour que
les gens puissent y aller donc comme
nous mon garçon je vais pas y aller on
fait quoi comme parents comment on fait
au Québec pour enrayer les wattspel ça
prend des intervenants toxicomanies dans
toutes les écoles ça prend des
interventions auprès des élèves
concrètes les jeunes devraient être
mieux avisés des risques qui en cours à
consommer ça moi je pense qu'ils le
savent pas et d'expliquer aux jeunes que
le THC c'est pas banal
je pense que nos jeunes sont
intelligents sont ouverts ils sont
capables de comprendre mais la
répression ça marche pas
97 puis 99% de THC je peux confirmer que
c'est complètement faux c'est simplement
peut-être je pourrais dire 97% de butane
puis 3% de THC est-ce que Max et ma
raison l'évapoteuses ont été envoyés à
un laboratoire spécialisé pour en
connaître la teneur en THC
on a vu avant la pause que les
vapoteuses d'huile de cannabis circulent
dans les écoles vise les jeunes ce qui
est totalement illégal alors on a voulu
savoir quel est le pourcentage de
cannabis dans ses vapoteuses qui sont
difficiles à intercepter
j'ai perdu tellement de choses à cause
des wax à cause de ça j'ai côtoyé des
bases au Centre jeunesse où il vit
actuellement Maxime compose durable
inspiré de sa consommation de Wax
[Musique]
le fond le jour où il se fait arrêter
par les policiers
ils m'ont amené dans une cellule et de
détention je suis resté là pendant
environ 7 ans
de ma vie parce qu'il me disait c'est un
livre j'ai une sortie d'une cellule de
détention le tout match c'est le moment
le plus marquant je pense que j'ai vu
qu'il y en a avec la consommation
donne un max de pain wax de blême
on cherche des pièces de solutions on
voudrait comme par exemple ça serait
demain matin je peux dire que ça fait un
an et demi que je frappe à des portes
sans trop de résultats
brigitte a tenté d'obtenir de l'aide des
policiers de sa région
de la police dans leur disant écoutez le
problématique les jeunes énormément à
l'école sérieusement j'ai sorti très
déçu de ma rencontre avec la sortie du
Québec parce que ça semblait banal pour
eux
maxime a fait le même constat il y a
deux ans
sur moi avec les boîtes
venait de chercher
mes cigarettes et mon lighter puis mes
deux Wacken qui avait ils ont redonné
ils ont redonné ça m'a fait trier pas
mal là
[Musique]
qui a eu lieu avant donc c'est ce qui
est compliqué pour les policiers d'avoir
ces informations là
la loi fédérale prévoit pas de teneur
mais ici au Québec on a décidé que
c'était les produits devaient être de 30
% de THC maximum tout ce qui est wax dab
sur
l'huile bref tout ça ben ça c'est pas
possible de vendre ça au Québec
justement parce que c'est des produits
qui sont de la concentration 80 85 90 et
même plus 2% de THC
les 12 vapoteuses de 6 marques
différentes ont été analysées par un
laboratoire spécialisé les résultats
confirment des taux très élevés de THC
c'est la marque gas gagne qui possède la
plus haute teneur soit 86 %, 4 autres
marques ont des taux qui se situent
entre 80 et
64%. il n'y a que la marque Diamond qui
s'approche de la limite de 30%
. les trois entreprises qui ont vendu
les vapoteuses sont situés dans des
communautés autochtones du Québec et de
l'Ontario
je prépare un reportage concernant la
vente illégale de Wax Pen je vous ai
envoyé deux courriels la semaine passée
cette semaine
ok donc il y a un propriétaire
comment il s'appelle
vous pouvez pas me donner son nom
les trois entreprises ont refusé de
s'expliquer par courriel et par
téléphone
07 a même ridiculisé notre demande
d'entrevue par courriel elle nous a
répondu laconiquement lol le siège
social de cette entreprise est située
dans cette résidence douche Wacken en
banlieue Hamilton
aucune réponse non plus du côté de moi
mais des Bulls à shannonville en Ontario
pour notre sécurité nous avons choisi de
ne pas entrer dans les commerces avec la
caméra je pense que les revendeurs sont
au courant des difficultés auxquelles
les policiers font face ils sont au
courant que c'est la chaîne est
difficile à remonter
est-ce que vous souhaiteriez que le
Québec
permettent l'achat de Wax pets si
c'était des dispositifs
contrôlés dans la qualité est assurée
qu'on connaît les produits à l'intérieur
oui je pense que ça pourrait être une
bonne idée on pourrait commencer par des
taux plus faibles de THC parce que ça
existe c'est là ça va circuler ça
permettrait peut-être justement de faire
de l'éducation par rapport à ces
usages-là est-ce qu'on préfère laisser
cette régulation là ce contrôle là au
marché illégal ou à l'état c'est ça la
question
le risque avec la drogue c'est que si tu
t'embarques là-dedans faut que tu sois
prêt à tout perdre parce que ça peut
arriver puis je le souhaite pas personne
mais c'est un film
si je voyais votre enfant aujourd'hui
physiquement
il est comment
ils cherchent son option c'est ce que je
me disais
mais rien il n'y a pas envie de rien
n'était plus envie de rien
c'est triste très triste
avez-vous peur qu'elle se suicide
toujours
[Musique]
parce que ça fait partie de son discours
très inquiétant surtout quand on connaît
le peu d'efficacité de la répression
alors ce qui nous reste c'est
l'éducation l'éducation et encore
l'éducation alors si dans votre
entourage des gens ont besoin d'aide
vous trouverez sur notre site internet
l'adresse de plusieurs ressources au
Canada